also as the president just foreshadowed
in our taskforce meeting today the
president has made a decision to suspend
all travel to the United Kingdom and
Ireland effective midnight Monday night
Eastern Standard Time
Chad Wolfe will describe the details of
that but again as the president just
suggested all of our health experts
presented information dr. pouchy will
reflect on some of those numbers made a
unanimous recommendation to the
president that we suspend all travel
from the UK and Ireland that will be
effective midnight Monday night Eastern
Standard Time again Americans in the UK
or Ireland can come home legal residents
can come home but as the Secretary will
detail they will be funneled through
specific airports and process
you